five signs of vitamin B12 deficiency and
how to get more vitamin B12 in your diet
vitamin B12 is a vital element your body
requires to carry out crucial functions
such as DNA synthesis energy production
and the proper functioning of your
central nervous system common signs of
vitamin B12 deficiency include feeling
tiredness all the time loss of appetite
pale or yellowish skin tingling
Sensations in your hand and feet and
cognitive problems such as memory loss
difficulty concentrating mood changes
and depression meat particularly organ
Meats such as liver are excellent
sources of vitamin B12 beef lamb and
poultry also contains significant
amounts of this vitamin fish like salmon
trout and tuna also contain good amounts
of vitamin B12 eggs are also a valuable
source of vitamin B12 milk yogurt and
cheese are some other good sources of
vitamin B12 stay healthy and stay
curious